hello we're live we're live we're live I didn't realize they
kicked the bonds 12 I didn't know oh my god I hear so many
of oh my god I hear so many of my voices right now my voice
oh where are they all coming from oh it's over here it's
came from oh one more there's one more tab oh it's here wait
where's the other one coming oh it's also here all right i
deleted all the tabs all right the voices oh all right i'll
meet the bgm okay okay i don't know i lost track of time
like when i was there in person It felt like I didn't
realize, like, no, I missed a Canadian national anthem.
Oh, Canada, our home and native land.
True patriot love.
And I forgot the lyrics right here.
That's how far I can sing the song.
Wait, actually, let me just do my national, my patriotism
once a year moment here.
I that's where I forget we don't have many chances to sing
the national anthem guys there's not a lot of things we're
very good at when it comes to sports guys I don't know if
you remember this but we lost in hockey hockey that's all we
have and we lost and don't get me started on curling don't
get me started on what happened to us in curling guys it's
all we have but
like these are our main sports curling and hockey and in
both of those sports for this year and last year.
We don't want to talk about it.
We don't.
So we don't have a lot of chances to sing the national
anthem, guys.
Not like America.
You literally, it's like a religious thing at that point.
You wake up every morning.
It's like, oh, say, can you see?
Oh, say, can you see?
For us, we wake up and go about our day.
We don't have to sing it at school, for those who don't
know.
There's not a lot of opportunities to sing the National
Anthem in Canada.
Alright.
So, like, me remembering the first four lines of the
National Anthem, you know, I did my best.
all right all right oh canada our home and native land true
patriot love in all of us command with glowing hearts we see
the rise the true north strong and free from far right oh
canada we stand on god for thee god keep our land glorious
and free oh Canada we stand on God for thee oh Canada we
stand on God for thee
soccer now let's go well in If you're, like, not in the West
Coast, you would also sing it in French, too.
But in West Coast, we don't really, we don't really care.
I'm sorry.
In West Coast, we, it's mostly just English.
It's, okay.
I assume the black jersey.
Yeah, the black jersey is kind of.
Why?
No.
He's just like, why are you singing?
Kick some ball!
Let's make it go.
As we're not being pussies about it and passing the ball for
20 hours.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's good.
What if it's offside, though?
I'm sorry.
Too soon?
Bro, that's so dumb.
Okay, so now my Twitter algorithm, This is my Twitter
algorithm.
I'm sorry, I'm getting engagement baited.
But, like, my Twitter algorithm right now is the Bible
Rivals drama, which, by the way, is still going strong.
But for those who don't even know, the tournament is still
going.
By the way, the tournament is soon.
It's, like, in two hours.
But the drama is still going strong.
And then it's also soccer drama.
It's World Cup drama and then and then art That's it really
pretty art from Japanese artists That's my Twitter algorithm
right now Um But anyway So for those who didn't know
Columbia scored against Portugal And then Oh do you guys
need a live stream counter I don't know I'm on the I don't
Okay I'll do it This is my first time doing this watch along
So I'm new to this.
Because the last time I did this, I watched this literally
at the stadium.
Let me set that up.
I'm not used to doing a timer for these.
Let me see if I can find a timer.
I don't even know what it's called.
I know I have a timer set up for stuff, but I never know
what it's called.
All right.
It's been a decade since.
Since Canada had a win.
Don't say that, bro.
No.
That's like, today's the day.
It'll be different, though.
It's gonna be different, guys.
Guys.
Hey, look.
This will be the year.
We're gonna break that streak.
Oh, there's so many empty seats in the stadium.
Nobody.
Like, there's so many.
But listen to no.
Obviously, people assumed that Is this a good timer?
Is this good enough?
I mean, to be fair, this is more so like it's Canada.
It's sort of.
You just think about the...
Like, because it was supposed to be South Korea versus
Canada.
And then, so like, because there's all Koreans in LA.
And a bunch of Koreans sold their tickets the moment.
I don't know.
Someone said, yes, BGM.
And then someone else, like, no BGM.
And then I don't know if you guys want a BGM or not.
let me adjust this I will do yeah we'll do that all right
counting up we'll count up zero nine twenty start oh it's
pause let's see 20
Oh my god, every time I feel like I'm there, I'm not there.
Alright, there we go.
Where is this?
I'll copy this.
Alright, this should be the right one.
Count up.
There we go.
Alright, and then we'll do...
Alright, that should work.
What are we counting for?
This is for the...
The match.
I have a multi-view, but I don't think I need...
Do I need a multi-view?
I feel like the main view is fine.
You see, I'm in Canadian colors too, guys.
I'm in Canadian colors.
No BGM?
Okay, no BGM.
Oh, yeah.
Anyway, what was I saying?
So, do you guys hear about...
So, Colombia was versing Portugal.
And they scored a goal against Portugal.
But it was considered offside.
I still don't fully understand offside, guys.
understand but then like i feel it's a stupid rule like no
like i think i don't know it's a little too extreme but like
anyway uh anyway the goal was considered offside because one
of the players toe was uh crossing the line and now it's
like how bad can it be and then like because they do like
three is like the olympics where they have like a uh measure
thing like a like an ai that determines if something's
offside so it's not the it's not through ref call oh it's
prevent players from spawn camping okay i guess that makes a
bit sense it's to prevent spawn camping the goal um so like
people were like oh shit that was close people were like um
we're saying like that's bullshit because it's like you know
it's just his toes but the memes were really funny
guys but the memes are pretty funny not gonna lie i will say
but let me show you guys the memes i think i saved it right
did i save it oh i didn't oh i did okay so all right it's
not the meme but this is what they mean by offside so so the
guy's toe so the ai was like offside and this tiny little
toe right there crossed offside for what
He's clearly offside.
Invisible.
Or not, yeah, but like the...
I guess like the detector or whatever thing.
And I...
It's right there!
He technically is offside.
It's like, those are the rules.
Rules are rules!
Oh shit!
No!
Get away!
That's all we have!
Please, I've already lost three tournaments in a row.
Now get them out of here.
This is all I have, guys.
I don't even have hockey and curling anymore.
This is all I have.
Anyway.
Oh, shit.
Go, David.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
No!
That's okay.
We have corn and cake.
That's all that's left.
My favorite one is the one whose junk was offside.
Doug, thank you.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Alyssa, thank you.
The super chat.
Thank you.
My country doesn't want to be as a big toe, and you laugh
how hard it was.
I'm sorry.
But like, okay, but the memes are pretty funny though Wait,
let me guys guys, okay Okay, but look at this funny meme
But but guys the memes are pretty funny though guys look at
this Come on guys guys
come on come on oh shit oh yay okay okay also this one I
saved some I saved this one too all right guys offside guys
it's clearly offside look at it look at it guys oh shit Oh
shit, give me a sec before I- Yes, come on!
Go offside!
Okay, but also, that's clearly offside, right?
Okay, that's- I mean, come on, yes, that's offside.
Not the noodle thing, bro.
um but anyway speaking of korea i don't remember why i
brought up korea earlier oh yeah because sub-korea lost so
sub-korea got fully eliminated um from world cup and like
they were so mad at the coach that they literally censored
him during the interview because his face angers the angers
the citizens of sub-korea so much that they had to censor
his like censor his face during the interview so i was just
like holy shit for those who didn't know they are so angry
like the interview like
he is some kind of fucking criminal yeah i was like oh my
god like holy shit they're so my and then like apparently a
bunch of restaurants and convenience stores have pulled up a
sign saying like they like the coaches banned from entering
this restaurant or something and I was like oh my god this
guy's basically like exiled like he's like practically
exiled from Korea like oh my god oh that's boom I just I
don't know what else to say I was just like he's banished
from Korea for this okay this is what this is like a news
channel by the way they literally like the broadcast of his
interview was half sensed like was mosaic out and you can't
even see his face he's like sent to the fucking shadow realm
oh my god he's shadow ben yeah
oh come on take his ball all
right bro's not even shadow ben He's just straight up bad
Did they bring in that one player that was injured They said
they were gonna sub him in In Canada by the way in Canada
Because they were saying like this was the game They're
gonna sub him in finally Because he was injured or something
He's like one of their strikers right No not the guy who
broke his leg There was another guy guy that didn't break
his leg.
I think it was something else.
The Korean coach is banned from restaurants in Korean town.
Oh my god.
Bro, don't go back.
You might as well stay in LA for a while, bro.
If you're being banned in LA already, bro, I don't even know
what's going to happen to you in Korea.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
I don't even know what's going to happen to you back there.
Bro, this literally is...
Bro, you know why they censored him?
Because his face pisses people off too much that they can't
show it on...
They can't show it on TV anymore.
Like, he's literally in witness protection program, right?
That's why they had to censor him.
mad which is understandable like they did you know they got
knocked out of the the World Cup like and it was like super
like um like against the team that they shouldn't have lost
to
yeah and they lost against South Africa but they were like
favored to win against South Africa oh shit let's go yeah oh
wait wait wait who touched it who touched it yeah who the
fuck are these two i don't fucking care about them they're
not even watching the fucking game they're not even bro cut
the camera those people aren't even watching like yeah who
are who are those people i don't fucking care like
yeah who are they the guy is on his fucking phone Who was
that Jessica Alba?
I don't fucking know.
I came here to watch soccer.
Not fucking seeing Jessica Alba.
Oh shit.
It's a free kick.
Oh.
Ah.
You should have jumped high, bro.
That's right.
Live with your regret.
Bro, what the fuck was that weak ass headbutt, bro?
What the fuck was that?
What is that?
Yeah, donkey understands.
Oh shit, I swear to God, bro.
If you let that guy score after your weak ass head butt, I
swear to God.
I swear to God.
Bro, what else are you gonna use that head for?
This is your job.
Man has a weak head, bro.
Sad.
That was close still.
Yeah, head game week, guys.
That free kick was practically, like, handed to him in a
silver platter.
Wait, did I tweet out live now?
I don't remember.
I was too busy watching soccer.
Yeah, I did.
I did not.
I thought I did.
Whoops.
Oh, it's hydration break?
Nope.
Okay.
Was live 20 minutes ago.
Live now.
But was also live.
Live since 20 minutes ago.
LaMau.
There you go.
Sorry.
I forgot to do it live now.
I did it.
It's hydration break, guys.
Guys, hydration check.
I need to grab...
I need to grab a cop drop.
Real quick, guys.
I'll be right back.
I mean, it's hydration check.
I can be right back real quick.
I'm back.
Oh, I forgot to stop the fucking timer.
Do I need to stop the timer?
I don't remember.
Do I need to stop the timer when they do a hydration check
or the timer go on?
No?
Okay.
Sorry.
The last time...
I've never done a live watch a lot of this before, so I
don't know.
When, like, when they did a hydration check during the field
game, when I was there live in person, um, when it did that,
I, uh, I didn't pay attention.
Okay, it doesn't stop the timer, okay.
That's good.
That's good to know.
me oh god look at that shit-ass head that weak-ass head game
guys bro like you jumped so high what was the point you just
nudged it sorry like what's the point of jumping that high
i'm just gonna like fucking do patty kick with the ball even
like look at the coach yeah that's right live with your
the ball was too high no he was look at that oh my you tell
like he i don't i'm sorry but like is the ball from this
isn't the ball too much head it was yeah do some fucking
football Lay off Cornelius
If only his neck was a little higher
You know in the end No matter what happens Even we lose Even
when we lose We made it to top 32 That's never happened
before for us Okay guys That's That's like This is a whole
new territory Us being good at a summer game fucking crazy
thanks global warming
the the pros of global warming Canada can finally compete in
soccer we coincidence
we started sucking at we started sucking ass in hockey after
global warming takes a takes a hot turn
After we finally experienced summer.
Yeah, we're acclimating the hot weather.
Yeah, the ice has melted.
It's time for water hockey.
Yeah, we suddenly lost our spark in curling and hockey.
The moment the ice caps started melting.
Coincidence?
I think not.
holy shit okay these are some good ass passes though oh
don't call for a ref no he's okay look he got up look guys
he's so okay get up get the up keep playing that's right
he's so fine keep they just kept playing that guy's like on
his knees that's right yeah limp No blood, no problem.
No, Liv, keep going.
He's healthy.
See, guys, he's walking.
He's fine.
I like, I even, it was like, we got to keep going, bro.
We got to keep going.
Patch your ass, I think it was super cheap.
Thank you.
You really talk about sports, and I'm so glad you took the
chance to do so, of us dragoons, but it's really funny to
see you get into it.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I like sports.
I like playing sports.
I like watching my country playing sports I like.
Canada has not been very good at sports that I like.
This is one of the sports that Canada is finally good at
that I like.
Let's see.
not a lot i like watching volleyball i used to like during
the olympics for like chadna's volleyball team is like
insane and i would i used to watch that with my with my
parents during the olympics and also batmanton too what
about hawk i'm sorry i'm no i'm canadian i'm sorry i'm not a
very big hockey fan even though i am canadian i think it's
because i'm not very good at hockey because i'm not good at
ice skating i just like sports i'm good at too you know like
i'm good at playing so because i know how to play that sport
so i know how to play volleyball and i know how to play
badminton soccer and like basketball but like i'm ass at ice
skating so i never played hockey so so i never really like
I've never, like, watched hockey.
I like watching fencing, too.
Hong Kong's really good at fencing.
And, like, it's pretty intense.
You know, when they, like, shimmy back and forth.
Yeah, I don't know why.
Hong Kong's just exceptionally really good at fencing for
some reason.
And I have no idea why.
We're just really, really good at it.
Someone's like, Hong Kong represent.
Hong Kong is like exceptionally good at fencing.
Like we would always have like one person that's just
really, really good at fencing for some reason.
And it's always like whenever they retire, whenever our Hong
Kong Olympian retires from fencing, we would get another
fencing, another person who's just really, really good at
fencing.
Like I don't know why.
We would always just have one guy that's just really good at
fencing in Hong Kong, no matter what.
No, okay, for those who don't know about it, there was a
instance where Hong Kong won a fencing Olympic match, was in
Italy, and then obviously, like, Italians were really mad,
and then in Pizza Hut in Hong Kong started selling pineapple
on pizza, like, did a special, did a special, like, bundle
discount for pineapple and pizza, and being like, yeah, we
won that's like BM they're like yeah guys who is pineapple
on pizza oh
shit that was a good juke oh my god that was an insane steal
from them oh my he's just like no hit my toes
that was crazy that's a crazy steal from him that's a really
good steal
wait who oh the head coach five years that's not that long
oh never mind he's been doing this for a while he's like 86
and i was like oh that's wild that guy's old old that's
right grab him yeah the ref didn't cough it's still fine
It's perfectly legal When are they gonna all get holy shit?
Oh my god, you better not fuck this up.
Come on.
Oh Oh, come on, bro Come on that was that was such a insane
steal and you just you just play slow They're scared of
offside guys They're like That's Bro Oh my god And then
straight back to South Africa
I feel like When they pause You know how they slowed down
there After the steel Oh that's great Oh You're not going
anywhere That's That's a fucking t-shirt crap He's like, get
back here.
Ref didn't, I don't hear no whistle.
I don't hear no whistle.
All right, check your toes, guys.
Check your toes.
Oh, shit.
Yes.
Weekhead.
Weekhead game.
Nice.
So if Canada lost, would you ban the coach from Canada?
Broken bond.
Thank you.
The super chat.
If Kanda loses, it's okay, we're all losers.
It's just a little...
This is Kanda's, not Kanda's week.
Honestly, even if, like, Kanda loses, the coach is going to
be, like, celebrated because we've never won a game before,
you know?
We've never made it this far.
We've actually never made it this far.
I'm just happy that we're here
I'm happy to be part of history You know why I didn't?
Oh my god No, no, no, no, no, no, no Offside!
Offside!
Yeah!
Oh,
oh, oh, oh, he's... Oh my god If I hit the face Well done,
Ken
Yeah, we're just happy to be here Now you get it But it
wasn't even just Which other Country Got offside Offside it
wasn't even just Columbia Like it's a magic spell It'll
happen again There was another one where like It was
supposed Was it Iran?
Yeah I remember Iran they scored like a goal that would
prevent from getting knocked out and then it was called
offside as well but that one was like that one actually was
offside i saw the 3d render and i was like oh yeah that's
offside what the fuck was that pass bro's coming for you
yeah but like he was actually offside like that guy was like
20 miles spawn camping the goalie like he was like ready to
shoot the goalie that was offside not the fucking toe though
what the fuck is that push ref ref oh my god what the fuck
was that push though right guy actually was like would be a
shame if something happens to you like can
you play soccer again or are you too old how old is ronaldo
How old, guys?
How old do you think Ronaldo is, guys?
How old?
Like, 40.
Yes, I was like, can you still play soccer to get you too
old?
But Ronaldo can still play soccer at 41 and still consider
one of the best.
Like, come on, guys.
Come on.
You know what?
I want to play.
You know what was his name?
that guy that guy plays soccer that guy was genetically
engineered to be a soccer player
he should just retire but holland he was that guy was made
in a lab
bro i'd be scared like even they lose even norway loses a
player as long as they have holland i think they'll be fine
like if they play like With one player less That guy is
literally like the entire team
Isn't he like the new record holder For Ref Yeah
Yeah he currently has all the world records right Holland I
know about Holland Because of all the funny memes about
Holland It's 40 minutes already Holy shit, it does not feel
like 40 minutes.
Guys, don't off, guys, guys, make sure your toes aren't.
Guys, whoa!
Yeah, we're playing hockey right now.
We're playing...
Bro, what the fuck was that push?
That guy, he's like, fuck that guy.
Did you guys see that push?
Fuck that guy.
That's why we're bringing hockey in.
No, I saw that so much in person.
It was crazy.
Like, the Canadian players were so aggressive.
I was like, you know what?
I was showing that funny Tom and Jerry clip.
I legitimately was like, what the fuck did the Canadian,
like when they gave the yellow card to the Canadian player
and the Swiss player, I was so confused why the Canadian
player got a yellow card.
Because like, when he got injured, like the Canadian
players, they ran up and started pushing the Swiss players
and be like, what the fuck?
Like, like, and I was like, what the fuck's going on?
Like, like, they were so, like, the Canadian players were so
mad.
And then, like, and then finding out that, no, it was, like,
like, oh, yeah, no, he deserved it.
Like, it was literally a, what?
Oh, my God, nice.
It was literally, like, a free kick.
Um, Bernard, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God.
There's a reason why the Geneva Convention...
was started because of Canada.
There's a reason why they made it for Canada.
Oh my god, wait, the guy's knees are already like injured.
Not injured, but you see like, you see like a scrape.
Run faster than!
No!
Wait!
Nice.
Okay, ref!
Ref!
What the fuck was- Get out of there, ref!
Get the fuck out!
Oh shit!
Oh, he missed!
Oh my god.
He missed.
Okay, but the ref.
Guys, the ref was in the way.
I'm out of here.
Also, Flipper, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Regarding that near face head, my stepbrite actually has
nose broken.
He was playing as goalie in high school.
I got kicked in the head when I played goalkeeper.
I don't know if that affected me in any way.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
But now, I think it was super chat.
There's a go-keen bristle that's 45 years still one of best
in the country.
I think it was super chat.
That's crazy for like, like had eye coordination and stuff.
Oh, what the fucking?
What the?
No!
Bro!
Head game!
Why is everyone having a weak head?
i'm watching like everybody oh my god that defender actually
clutched it holy that whoever was behind the goalkeeper oh
my god he's so lucky he's so lucky his weak ass goalkeeping
couldn't save it okay he might not be a weak ass dude i'm
sorry it's the spirit it's the spirit oh my god their necks
are weak as fuck he's not bad he's not back but you know I
mean legitimately he got a he literally got a free like get
out of jail free card with that that shit was crazy that
defender clutched it up
today is the day of no head for Canada
oh oh okay that was a good oh well yes corner corner he
touched it he touched it ref he touched it ref come out oh
he's like back up back up the coach he was good they're
gonna push the ref to push the ref.
Did you see that?
They were ready to push him.
Do you see the player?
He's like, guys, guys, no.
We don't push him.
We don't.
That has to be a penalty kick, right?
What is it?
Okay.
How is he?
Oh, that guy got, wait.
Did he get hitting the balls, though?
Bro!
No.
Oh, no penalty.
No penalty.
Oh my god.
I liked how the player was like, nope, guys, we don't push
the ref.
Guys, we don't push the ref.
That's so funny.
Is it a goal kick?
Ah.
Oh, you can hear the booze.
You can hear the booze.
Bro, the ref literally, like, he was in the way, too, at one
point.
While the Canadians were trying to pass.
I think Canada has more chances to score.
So we're, like, fumbling a lot when it comes to it.
Okay.
You're so much faster.
Oh, my God, yes.
The push.
The fucking push.
I see.
Bro, that's crazy.
Soccer goes so wild.
One more minute.
Oh, they're cheesing it.
They're playing the pass game.
Yeah, I think Canada's worse during second half.
I agree.
First half, they're really, really strong.
is where they start to crumble a little.
I don't know why.
Whoa!
Ref!
Push him!
Push him.
No, I'm joking.
Do not... I'm joking.
What?
Oh, you called that.
You called that.
Bro, get up.
Get up, bro.
Get up.
Ref!
What?
Give me the replay.
Show me the replay.
Show, ref got paid.
Oh, now you're not showing me the replay.
Oh, replay.
What, yeah.
Bro, it's the grass, bro.
Half time dodged the issue.
Roll the clip!
Right, Canna.
Oh my god, that's bad for us.
We're so bad during second half.
Bro, literally, during the Switzerland game, I got out of my
seat to buy a jersey, and then was two minutes late, and
apparently Swiss scored in the first 30 seconds of second
half.
I was like, what the fuck?
Yeah.
Oh, pause the timer.
Sorry.
sorry we're a little we're a little ahead i'm gonna use i'm
gonna do a bathroom break guys i'll be right back
i'm back i would have to reset four or five seconds i can do
that 40 or i'll just stop 45 zero uh let's
see i'm trying to fix this real quick
All right.
Whoops.
Pause.
There we go.
We got it.
All right, guys.
Make sure to hydrate, everybody.
Emo, stuff.
Papa, Buzz.
A bite.
Sorry, Buzz.
Bite.
Vin.
Nexi.
Affiliate.
Burr.
And Solid.
A.K.
Cyber.
And Medi-Alan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'm healing Doki.
I'm a little nervous only because Canada from what I've seen
is not very good during the second half I think it's mostly
because like momentum's lost you know you know it's like a
pause you know so then usually like that fucks up with the
momentum and everything so like I literally I saw it in
person I was just like what are you guys doing I was just
like yeah so so it's a little
But we made it this far, guys.
We made it this far.
Yeah, they lose pressure.
Yeah, they lose focus and pressure, I would say.
So we'll see how it goes.
Let's see.
Oh.
My voice is dying.
I haven't had a break yet, so this is usually my rest day.
And, like, I get very...
passionate.
Maybe the anger of the ref would try them in the second
half.
Ref!
What are you doing?
I know like referees, they grab referees from all around the
world, and then rotate them up.
So, just so like to be more fair.
So there's no like country biases and stuff with the refs.
Guys, don't worry.
They'll alt in the second round, guys.
They're saving their alt for the second round.
Oh, is it Portuguese?
Oh, my God.
Apparently, okay.
Like I said, it's my algorithm.
Oh, my God.
Wait, is this real?
Apparently, the president of South Korea ordered an into his
ministry of sports following the team's elimination of from
the world cup so he's he has he's like he's trying to figure
out what the fuck happened there's an investigation that was
opened to be like what's going on and apparently they were
investigating the team's hotel trying to see if the
accommodations were to blame for the poor performance
against south africa bro oh my god i do wonder what happened
i do wonder because like uh south korea is like was like the
favorite like what had changed between the south africa
match and like their other matches how did you fumble it
that bad
what happened since it's half time i just want to say it's
my birthday thank you for introducing me to of you doing,
bringing so much fun.
Of course, thank you for coming and watching and dropping by
and hope you have a great birthday, Laura.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Lord.
Yeah, happy birthday.
I will say that...
Like, I don't think their coach, their coach, is their coach
good or not?
Because, like, I read a little bit about their coach, but he
was part of the, like, he was one of the most famous players
in the World Cup.
He was, like, he was part of the team that got to the fourth
place in the World Cup.
What was the fourth, right?
Like, is he, is he a good coach or is he a bad coach?
No, he's ass.
Oh, so he's just really good.
Oh, I read a little bit off of, like, a bit of a news
article, because, like, you know, during, like, the, um yeah
i was gonna say is he just really bad at coaching but like
is he just really bad at coaching but a really good player
in general yeah i was just gonna say like sometimes like
people are like they can be good players but not good
coaches because some some people can have like really good
like understanding of the fundamentals but they can't like
execute it properly so you know like sometimes like good
coaches doesn't mean good like really good player on the
field I read that, like, originally they wanted to get a
foreigner to coach Team Korea, right?
So, but, like, they decided in the end to get, like, I
forgot his name, to get the one that has their whole face
censored right now.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, good players don't always make good
teachers.
I agree with that.
Yeah, he was, like, a legend during, like, when he was a
player.
Just because, like, there's a lot, especially, like, in
esports, there's a lot of really good players, like, really
good coaches that aren't really good play, like, you know,
their rank might not be really high, but they understand,
like, the fundamentals really, like, they understand
strategies and the fundamentals really, really well.
They just don't have, like, the skills in-game to, like,
execute it for their own rank, but they can apply it for
other players and for other teams.
Like, they have that big brain.
But their hands can't keep up with it.
Yeah, those who can't do teach is not accurate.
Wait, it's not?
Same with players being coaches, too.
Yeah, I agree.
No team has won a World Cup with a foreign board.
that that's that's interesting i didn't know that a
foreign-born coach it's like i mean like usually it's like a
national like a not like a patriotic thing like a
nationalist thing you would want to be coached by someone
from your own country you know because it's like you know
they're from your own country it makes sense like you want
to have like national pride it'd be like a bit more weird to
be coached by someone that isn't born from your country
because you're trying to my country that's good enough to
coach me you know yeah
you understand your coaches and players better it just feels
like you would feel like oh yeah you want to be led by
someone from your own country because it is the world cup as
american though we need it ponchettino Wait, where's Ponce
Tino from?
Togito.
We need him.
Togito, understand.
Where is he from?
Oh, he's from Argentina.
No, that's no, no, it's true.
No, no, you're right.
I see from Argentina.
No, you do.
We all need an Argentina coach.
We all.
Everyone needs an Argentinian coach.
Alright, start.
Oh, wait.
Is it start?
Oh, not yet.
Not yet.
JK, they'd like, we didn't start yet.
Where is Ted Lasso?
But it didn't work.
But wait, did Mexico got a coach from Argentina as well?
out?
Oh, he was asked.
Okay, there's always like one.
There's always one, guys.
They just skipped him.
Had so, oh, against Messi.
Okay, yeah, that sort of makes sense.
Against, yeah, that makes more sense.
Guys, you know what I found out?
I found Oh, hey, there's Ted Lasso.
Ted Lasso.
ad
speak of ted lasso holland holland what happened to him why
did he became an uber driver in ted lasso's world holland's
an uber driver no that's my ad right now i'm watching the
ads on my stream.
Steve Carell.
My coat fell off.
In an alternate universe, if he never discovered soccer and
his dad didn't make him play soccer slash football, he would
have been Ted Lasso's Uber driver.
Dad.
Boom, boom, boom.
Did you see like the Viking roll?
That, um, uh, oh wait, we're about to start.
That Nori did for their warm-up.
That shit was cool.
I saw a clip of it.
Like, like I said, everything started showing up in my
algorithm ever since the Canada versus Switzerland game.
Wait, I'll, I'll send you guys a clip after we lose our win
or draw.
I don't know.
After we lose our win.
I think it's I think it's corny that uh Norway benched a
majority of their starters against who was it I don't even
remember who it was which team were against I think that's
corny ass as hell that they benched all of them
yeah oh France was it against France because it could have
been like and was this anything I mean but and Boppe versus
Holland and but yeah again and Boppe versus Holland which
would have been a really fun game to watch And they, like,
benched.
Yeah, they benched all of them.
Just because, like, they didn't.
They want to rest all their players.
Yeah, so they don't want to.
Yeah, but still, it would be cool to see.
Embapé versus Holland.
I remember which team was it.
Which team was it where, like, both teams were trying to
stand back.
So they'd get a better...
To get a...
Oh, that has to be the captain.
The guy that was telling everyone to back off there earlier.
The guys.
um but like which team what which two teams were it when
they were fight like facing each other was it algeria versus
austria where they were trying to one country was trying to
like sandbag so so they could get an easier uh so they get
an easier matchup yeah i saw like screenshots of like
people's faces where the guy shot the goal and his team was
mad at him.
They were like, what are you doing?
Yeah, both teams wanted to avoid Spain.
I don't remember which one was, but I saw like pictures of
the guy.
He shot the goal and his team was like, what are you doing?
No one wants to, yeah, no one wants to play against Spain.
Oh, I'm about to start.
All right, start.
Right click to avoid speed.
I did.
I set the timing.
I'm like one second behind, but that's fine.
Like, like my timer is one second behind.
I'm watching it live.
My timer is one second behind.
Whoa.
Promise Dave is off the bench.
Wait, isn't he as our striker, right?
Oh, I forgot.
Right side's Canada now.
I was like, what are you doing?
Go!
Go to the goal!
I was like, wait, that's Canada's side.
Oh.
Can we grab it?
Yes!
Nah!
We're so...
How can you miss that one shot?
The death Two guys missed They all missed Is it a yes or is
it a no?
Bro, what was that?
Bro, the guy, I told you We're so bad at second half Why you
play with my emotions like this?
Oh, that hit that hit right i haven't i'm i bet a lot of you
guys are surprised that i had no ball but i legitimately
learned a lot from just watching i i did a lot of catch i
didn't learn i'm a fast learner when it comes to sports
because i do play soccer so it's like i do play football so
it's like i it's easy for me to pick stuff up for like pick
things up and like just know about like I know ball a
lot of things I also like I just had the algorithm too
because I used to play I used to play from middle to high
school like for my varsity teams so I watched the South
Africa I watched with some yeah I want I used I watched the
last time I watched World Cup was when the Vuvuzelas was a
thing the one thing was just I think off-size just a stupid
But like in more so of like Oh my god She lost her phone I
just I don't know Offside is so such a weird role I don't
I understand because they don't want to spawn camp the
goalkeeper But it's so confusing It's always so confusing
Because it feels so like Nick picky sometimes When they call
for offside Like it feels like Sometimes when things aren't
offside, you know, and it's such a shitty feeling when, you
know, you're, you know, if you're there in person and you're
like, your team scored a goal, but then they call offside.
Like, it is simple, but I mean, more so, like, you don't
know if it's offside until they call it offside, you know?
Because, like, you as a viewer can't see offside.
Yeah.
It's so hard to see as a viewer.
this sucks because like you don't know it's an offside until
the goal is scored
like i get it yeah oh my god you guys like it's my ball yeah
you see if you're looking at it i don't know i see it i'm
just like i don't know it's okay get up get up bro get up
all right how did he get hit where in this head did he what
what that's his toe
up no you can't okay is that our ball who's doing yeah
that's our ball okay i was like bro bro he was like my head
and then you see him like
your sub toe owly oh you're too fair okay have you guys ever
seen like was it back was it basketball player or or is like
basketball players and soccer players like feet is like it's
like because the shoes are like A lot of their, like, the
toes is, like, really weirdly shaped now because of, like,
the stress from, like, the shoes.
It's, it's, it's, it's, like, I want to say weird.
It's, like, interesting how, like, the feet is just
differently shaped.
Yeah.
Like, yeah, it fucks up your toes.
Okay, I don't know if I should show it on stream for you
guys.
Why would I know that?
Because like, I don't remember who it was.
I don't know if it was a football player or a basketball
player.
But like he took off his shoes and they're like, what the
fuck?
And it's a little like, it was a quote retweet.
And they're like, what?
Like they're like, what's wrong with his feet.
Like, you know, like, bro, what's wrong with his feet?
Was it LeBron?
Let's see.
I know, like, I think it was like Messi and Ronaldo also had
like a similar photo like today that showed up and people
were like, what happened?
Oh yeah, no, oh, no, get out!
Get out of here!
What?
Okay, who was it?
Who was it?
A free kick?
Oh, you called that!
No, no, you're right.
You're right.
Oh, wait.
We get the free kick.
Okay, bro, the guy was like gripping.
It's surprising to see what you can get away with in soccer.
Never mind.
Oh, we get the free kick.
I thought it was him fucking grabbing onto the guy's shirt
and like holding it for a fucking dear life.
Like.
it's so it's surprising what you can like get away with like
that guy couldn't even get close he was just like no there's
so much contact no i saw a lot of it especially like people
against holland like because holland is like fucking built
like a goddamn beast like you should see the clips of
Everyone trying to, like, hold on to Holland to, like, stop
him.
Wait, who is penalized?
Yeah, he doesn't go down.
I mean, he's, like, a bouncy ball.
But I told you, he was, like, genetically engineered to play
soccer.
Like, that's...
But I saw a clip of him, like, of them trying to tackle
Holland.
Oh, shit!
Oh, come on.
Yellow card!
What did he do?
Show me the replay.
Oh, never mind.
No, no, that, no, no.
No, never mind.
Don't show me the...
Oh, what?
Wait, did he even kick him?
I mean, yeah, he just wrapped him around.
Yeah, no.
That's...
Don't show me the replay.
Erase the replay.
Guys, he just grazed him, guys.
He was... He was... You know, when we said football, he got
a little confused, guys.
It was just a little oopsie.
He just wanted a hug.
That's AI.
It's AI, guys.
I can't believe the AI generated our players grabbing on
him.
oh shit yeah no during by the way it's because Canada
doesn't do like I think does Canada not do that pussy shit
where they like pass each other because like during the
Swiss game like they didn't do it during the Swiss game oh
my god no get him out no where's the defense where's our
defense oh oh grab him yes yes oh my god yes that's right
that's right okay okay okay we slowed it down we slowed it
down it slowed down oh so it's illegal for men to give hugs
no no yes good catch good catch yeah that's a good catch
that's a catch okay anyway as i was saying because like um
can it like in the in the cat canadian stadium like i would
always hear them boo like it when they do the pussy ass
passing shit that they would do to the goalie to like uh
yeah like to draw the timeout where they will pass the
goalie pass to the left defender pass back to the goalie
pass back to and then every time they did that the Canadian
stadium was just like boo boo like it was every time like I
get it it's like frustrating because I felt I was so fucking
bored that shit is lame yeah I hate that strategy that shit
is so fucking lame like like i said it was like 150 passes
switzerland and then 40 passes canada during like after half
time and i was like bro like i feel like canada doesn't do
it like hold hold
director thank you the super chat thank you thank you my iTV
stream being behind doki stream feels like I'm getting
spoilers from Doki for this match right now.
Thank you to Super Chat.
Thank you.
It's not a foul if he's still... Oh, no.
That's the captain, isn't he?
Oh, shit.
Is he bleeding?
Oh, fuck.
Oh.
Wait, what role?
What position does he play?
Oh, no.
That red card, ref.
Ref.
card red card wait wait what what position of that guy does
that guy play left back left wing oh this is bad oh this is
bad oh they're mad not they're mad oh no they're doing the
wave now they cool Be cool.
He's like, that's hockey.
Never mind.
Be cool.
All right, here you go.
All right.
Trigger warning.
LeBron's feet.
But this is what LeBron's feet looks like now.
Trigger warning.
That's what I meant.
I don't, I know like, let me take it fun.
The one for the soccer one that I saw today.
Not looking.
I'm reading right now.
Yes!
The rep didn't call!
That's looking right!
Jesus Christ, where are you passing, bro?
Leonie, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I heard Japan's going to use their white jersey.
And it's like the most popular jersey.
like more popular than the blue one just because it looks no
no okay I thought the that was the yes oh ref what what are
you fucking kidding me boo boo what you're gonna call that
you're gonna what what did he do
what was that replay the Replay.
Times 2.
Times 0.5 speed.
I also hate Matara.
Eh.
Oh yeah, but I saw your DMs, Matara.
Sorry, I was just really tired.
He's on Polymarket.
Find his account in Polymarket.
Report.
Take that account down.
Boo!
all touch the ref he had to stop that ref had to be paid off
i don't care you
can imagine me down injured and 75 000 people doing a wave
over your body like being teabagged by a stadium thank you
for the super chat uh during ordin thank you thank you oh my
god that was so fucking that that i don't know that that
that I don't know.
I don't think that was the right call for the ref.
Fire him!
I don't think that was a good call.
Bench the ref.
I demand a ref swap.
You can hear Kanda booing.
Kanda's so mad right now.
There's a reason why it's the Geneva suggestions.
Blur the ref.
Censor him.
I don't even want to see him.
If I see his, now I understand the Koreans now.
I, if I see his face, I'm going to get angry.
I understand.
Censor the ref.
No, no.
Oh, oh, okay.
Nice.
Padden from Tim Hortons.
It's not suggest a pad from Canada.
don't make us bring back the riots the stanley cup riots
holy shit that was so close why couldn't Canada come on
there's a reason why our riots have a Wikipedia page
forced him to work at Tim Hortons don't bat him from terms
to Tim Hortons every day.
Vancouver might not survive another riot.
Luckily, there's no Canada games in Vancouver.
Oh my god, come on, come on.
Push him!
It's fine!
Grab his shirt!
Oh, that is so smart!
That is so smart!
That's right!
I checked, by the way.
I checked to see if there is like any more Canada games just
in case like to see if there's gonna be another Wikipedia
entry I want to know if there's gonna be another Wikipedia
article
where are the heads why is everyone's head game so weak
today oh come on you're passing to the goalie bro That's not
our goalie, bro.
That's not our goalie.
Wrong colors.
Oh, no, no, yeah, that was definitely our.
Yes, come on.
Guys, score some fucking goals.
Run faster.
Run so much faster than the goalie.
No!
Oh, my God.
Bench him.
Bench that guy.
Bro, is that the same guy that defended the last goal too?
Bro, that defender is so fucking good.
That is a really good defender.
That guy, I think that's the same guy that defended the
other goal as well.
The offside.
Bench the goal.
No, bench that guy.
No, that guy is the MVP.
go handily block two goals that
was close that was really close come on oh what another what
a surprise more weak head what a fucking surprise is anyone
surprised i swear to god if i go to the bathroom and they
score a fucking go i swear to the fucking guy Thank you.
Thank you.
First of all, go Canada.
Go.
Second, it's amazing.
This ref is Portuguese and you still have 150% South African
blood.
We lose.
We right.
Look, guys, we don't do well with losses and we're not in
Canada right now for this game, guys.
I'll have you know.
Canadians do very, very, very poorly when it comes to
losing.
Out of any country for any sport you do not want a canadian
you don't want like canadians to be mad when they lose why
did you get closer why okay oh my god please please someone
trips somebody i need a yellow card right now i why would
whoa okay yes all right nice okay i'm gonna give him a treat
I called it.
Wait, did he actually get a yellow card?
Oh, shit.
I didn't actually...
I didn't mean...
I didn't want you to actually get a yellow card.
Guys, I'm not that...
Guys, oh, my God.
Canada.
I'm not that important.
You wanted this.
Oh, my...
Canada.
Oh, Canada.
though yeah you asked for it the monkey fall girl okay all
right well if there's a hydration break i'm gonna use the
bathroom too i'll be right back guys
back just in time oh my gosh i'm back covo thank you for the
20 gift of ships they could thank you uh johnny ashtram juge
boy i'm jay papa But man, Mike, Maddie, Nexy, Cyber, Solid,
thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you, thank you
guys for all the support.
It's been fun doing this watch a lot with you guys.
All right, here we go.
Oh, I swear to God, you passed the goalie one.
I swear to God, you passed you the left of the vendor one
more time.
I swear to the fuck, oh my, boo, boo, okay, there we go.
There you go, there you fucking go.
Yep, pass it one more time, your fucking goalkeeper.
Do it again.
Oh, come on.
His?
What?
Check his blood.
Check his passport.
Check the referee's passport.
I'm starting to doubt that he's, I'm starting to doubt that
he's Portuguese now.
I'm sorry.
I demand a DNA test.
I am at a fucking DNA test.
I need his family tree.
I need to see his family tree.
I didn't know there's no South African blood at all.
Turkey, the fuck.
Bro.
I need to know.
I need his entire genealogy.
Check his fucking bank account.
Damn check find his poly market check if his email is
associated with any poly markets.
Are you serious?
No.
Oh, fuck.
Okay Scores some fucking ghosts.
I even thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you That's right grab his shirt.
It's legal.
Okay, but like Check his DNA Mod check his bloodline
good you see i don't want to jinx it because i'm worried
that oh that he touched it whoa my god it's still in
rotation what the fuck don't call it don't oh my god you
watch the scan there the other games too i don't know maybe
semi the thing is i maybe semi i don't know do you guys want
to watch more of these because like i'm more paid i'm really
passionate because it's canada you know i hate i hate this
referee censor him mosaic this right guys i understand the
korean news news network now i hate a space censor him Send
it out.
Boom!
Pass, yeah, pass it to another defender.
Oh, and then you're passed back to the goalkeeper.
Yeah, pass it back to the fucking goalkeeper.
Oh, yeah, now what are you gonna do?
Pass it to your right defender?
Oh, whoa, what a surprise.
What a fucking surprise.
300 passes.
Yeah, fuck it.
Just run.
Just fucking run.
yeah just what are you gonna do pass it again to the fucking
goalkeeper oh oh yes no no no get out grab his shirt grab
him oh yes that's good 500 passes messy thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you uh we'll just yeah I don't
know we'll see how it goes
bring it back come on David if you don't do it we riot if
you don't do it we take your passport David
before they pass it to the rep at this point if the rep
starts playing I won't even be fucking surprised i don't
wanna if the ref fucking ref whoa okay there we go all right
that's fine there we go all right you can uncensored him get
it yeah you know he's all right he's all right if they don't
score we destroy alberta where's davy's from we'll get his
hometown will riot where he lives
nah you are for just one second you are oh that was a good
steal you're so much faster you're so much faster he is from
Edmonton guys we all meet up in Edmonton oh that was a nice
attempt we all after this game I'll see you all in Edmonton.
I'll see you all.
That was a good try.
Good try.
He fucked up.
The placement.
It should pass.
Ain't no way anyone's going to Edmonton.
That's why we riot in Edmonton.
It'll be the most fun thing they've ever experienced in
Edmonton.
Oh, wow.
Pass it to the left defender.
Then pass it back to the goalie.
Then pass it back to the right defender.
Come on.
I know you want to.
Wow.
Who's surprised?
Oh, you're not going to pass the goalie.
Oh, there we go.
There's the goalie.
Boo.
I fucking hate that.
It's so boring.
It actually is so fucking boring.
Then crashing out.
that's what's like i kind of doesn't do it tana's like no
fucking pussy we grab shirts and get yellow cards because
that's how we roll our ice caps are melting and this is the
closest we we can get for hockey what if he just not liking
this chat this is peak football you see canada's not used to
this you know you see canadians hate that because we we're
just like gas gas gas gas Fuck the edging Like Canadians
just want to fucking go We grab shirts and shoot
Oh god that save was crazy That was a crazy save though I I
appreciate goalkeepers As a goalkeeper Everything is already
broken We're getting flooded.
It's on.
Too late.
Meet up in Edmonton for this riot.
But Gordon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sorry, thank you for the super chat.
Scott, I didn't get the super chat.
Thank you.
Seven minutes with no goal.
I know.
Yes!
Push him again!
Now that's hockey!
Now that's grass hockey!
We're playing hockey now.
Welcome to Canada.
That's not...
Now it's our turn.
grass hockey oh my god please just please now is our turn oh
my that's how you headshot oh no now we're doing it we just
started oh no now we're at passing.
No, what happened to us, Canada?
Now the crowd doesn't care who it is.
They're just so tired of this pussy footing around.
I've become what we've hated.
We've become what we hated the most.
Oh, I'm surprised they just let him do that.
Oh.
What?
Why did he pass like that?
Yes!
Oh, God.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Come on, Davies.
Come on.
We're going to Edmonton, Davies.
Don't make us riot in Edmonton.
No one wants the riot there.
No.
Oh, no.
We don't want a riot in Edmonton, Davies.
Better fucking score that goal.
Edmonton must burn.
Come on, come on, Dailies!
What was that, Hedy?
Bro!
Where's your girlfriend right now?
Are you serious?
There's nothing to burn in Edmonton.
Yeah.
Oh, why?
Um, it's just me being dumb.
You guys are gonna have to start counting.
You guys are gonna figure out how to count this.
Our boyfriend.
You know?
Got practice.
I hate it.
I don't like watching during overtime.
It's... I really don't like watching during overtime.
I don't want to be sad, guys.
I'm gonna have to be sad, don't I?
Why?
Who's behind me?
Find them!
Davies is not there!
Davies ain't no time traveler!
Davies no fucking...
I don't know, he's not in the Matrix, bro!
You can't just TP!
Oh.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
Are you fucking serious?
No, no whistle, no whistle, no whistle, yeah!
No whistle, no whistle, no whistle.
He thinks my guy is tracer.
Come on Davies, come on Dave, what are these passes?
Bench him!
Bench that guy!
Oh no, oh no, yes, yes!
Oh my god, yes, yes, the grass!
The grass is shit, let's go!
Oh my god.
Davies, come on, Davies.
I'm fucking booking my ticket to Edmonton, Davies.
I'm ready to join that riot, Davies.
Oh, there's the passes.
There's the passes.
Oh my god.
I've... 90 whole minutes of just passing.
I'm ready to burn down Edmonton, Davies.
Bring back the riots!
No!
Just fucking go!
This meta shit!
Guys, I need new patch notes.
When will new patch notes come out?
Oh no!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Wonderful save.
Oh my, this is worse than triple support.
Are you?
What are these?
Bro, replace the guy.
Replace this.
Replace the right guy.
Replace that guy.
This guy fucking sucks at passing.
Put him back in defense so he can practice passing at this
point.
So, yes, they're down one man.
Because it was, he tripped and fell himself.
Okay, Davies, bro.
Like, we're not here to play right now.
Davies.
Davies, bro.
What are you trying to do?
Trick shot in, bro?
What is this like, whoa, switch back and forth?
What?
Oh, shit.
I actually stopped the timer.
I was so mad.
I'm sorry.
What, what, what's the time at?
Guys, I stopped.
I was so mad.
I actually stopped the timer.
What's it at, guys?
I don't know where it's at.
Can someone do it in like one hour, like calculator via
hours for me?
Ha ha ha.
What is it?
Like one hour and what?
One hour and 25?
Okay.
We'll start it here.
Okay, the timer is one second behind, but we're accurate.
There we go.
Is it correct?
Oh, I don't know how to do it with the timer.
I have my time the timer I have can't set it for it it just
counts hours I don't know how to fix it I'm sorry I don't
know I'll fix it I don't have enough time to fix it I swear
no do not pass it to this man where does this man live who
is this guy where does he live we're not rioting in Edmonton
anymore I want to know who that guy is I don't know Where he
lives, where he was born, we're going to this city.
We're going to this guy's city.
We're going.
Next scene, they was super chat thinking, they, I just
didn't want to do math, next scene.
I just didn't want to do math.
I'm too, I'm, I'm, I'm here to fucking watch soccer.
I don't even know.
Uh.
Joel, the English super chat thing, thank you.
You should watch the Mexican-Mexico game now that you're an
honorary Mexican.
Maybe.
The thing is I will be...
Oh, oh.
Dating cities!
What was the past date?
Never mind.
Back to Edmonton.
Back to Edmonton, we go.
I'm...
I want to walk away so badly.
I want to...
I'm so mad.
I want to walk away.
Like, we need more passing, like, practice, guys.
We, what the fuck was that?
I just want to walk away.
I'm so disappointed.
Oh, wow.
Let's pass.
At least these guys know how to fucking pass.
You can see it.
Try.
I don't think I see it.
I can see books.
of teams still try.
I don't think we need to try.
I don't think I, they're playing.
I don't think they're trying.
Oh, no.
No!
Yes!
Oh, I think, guys.
Oh, God.
Yes.
Good.
Alright, the ref's back.
The ref's back.
I don't know.
His girl from South Africa cheated on him or some shit let's
go let's fucking go
I I'm gonna walk oh I need to get well I'm walking away I'm
fucking walk I'm walking away I'm getting water
I will say this was not the can that I saw versus
Switzerland this is this was this was not
Switzerland I saw saw against Switzerland this I this I I
I'm disappointed this this is not the Canada I saw and saw
against Switzerland bro they when they were against
Switzerland bro I did not see all these miss passes all
these whiffs
I don't care if like they have a bad bracket is just like
being in top 32 is already a huge accomplishment and like
top 16 would be like just the cherry on top you know like
even they get eliminated but like what i'm most frustrated
about is that this is this is piss poured soccer right now
this is oh yes let's go that's all i need yes it's a god of
head trauma oh
that's all they need I just need to fucking shit talk to
them.
That's all they need.
Tough love.
Yes!
Yes, let's go!
Now that's soccer!
Edmonton is saved!
Counseling my ticket to Edmonton.
We rioted in LA.
No riot today.
Yeah, it'll live
It'll live It'll live That's right, you don't have your
fucking defender to kick that goal for you You don't have
your fucking lifeline no more You used up your lifeline
Hold, hold, hold, hold
Oh, I'm so nervous Come on, yes, yes Hold You just need a
survive three minutes
oh shit i don't want to watch this is tense this is fucking
tense oh who scored the guy with the head trauma what's the
name no no no no okay okay that was so risky that is way too
fucking risky i don't i don't know i don't trust that
oh my god Come on, two minutes.
Two minutes.
Just two minutes.
Just defend.
Just fucking defend.
We need 20 players in the goal right now.
20 players in the goal.
Oh my god, the scoreboard.
I'm sorry.
I was so happy.
All right.
Oh.
Offside.
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
Guys, just pass the defender.
Pass back to the goalkeeper.
Pass the defender.
Just do what they did.
Do the meta.
This is the one time you have to do the meta, bro.
The one fucking time you get meta.
Okay.
Take your time.
Take your fucking time.
Oh, no.
No.
Okay.
Oh, 40 seconds.
oh 40 seconds oh shit 20 players back in defense just put
them all in defense bro just put the matter you just need a
stop yes yes keep going keep fucking going yes just keep
going just they're adding another minute just fire him
cancel cancel him
one more minute they said one more minute they had to add
one more minute come on just one more minute you just gotta
survive one more minute come on you know what sucks i can't
do a live watch a line where if they oh god no no no no no
no no no no no no no
being in seconds
okay oh fuck okay okay 15 hold the line hold the fucking
line yes let's go keep holding the ball keep holding the
ball oh god oh god they have to add the seconds because he's
holding the ball just just pass just pass just pass
hold the line hold the fucking line
yes top city somebody you know who cares team cat of my lost
marvelous but we won we're top 16 in world cup we're top 16
in fifa baby and let's go and ggs nori i'm not even even
close for the first time in history.
That's right.
South Africa.
South Africa Wiki World Cup.
How many times have you qualified for a World Cup?
Huh?
Oh, wait.
Oh, this is their first time.
Wait.
Oh, my God.
They have the similar record as us, guys.
They have a similar record as us.
Never mind.
We're just the same.
But, but, we're top 16.
We're top, we're both babies.
But, but we're top 16, baby.
We're top fucking 16.
Raid, riot canceled.
We're riot, where are we?
Are we still in LA?
Guys, we're not so different after all.
No more passes to the...
It's funny, the moment I started shit-talking, Kat, and then
we scored.
It's like they felt my spite.
They felt my anger.
It was a coughing baby versus coughing baby fight.
Yeah.
Riot postponed.
Oh, no.
We're absolutely going to be destroyed by Netherlands.
Like, no, 100%.
There's no way.
There's no way we're surviving that.
There's no way There's no way we're gonna live through Is it
still in LA?
You lucked out this round Edmonton GG
Cyber, they used to reach out Thank you, thank you Is it
still in LA, guys?
No, Texas We right in Texas Because we know what's gonna
happen guys we know what's gonna happen guys we know what's
gonna happen when we fight the netherlands but we riot in
texas guys wait wait we gotta bring the canadian stanley cup
to texas guys it's the world tour it's the world tour the
riot tour where's your bro it's the Netherlands what the
fuck do you want us to do I think they're like three feet
taller than our players too it's the fucking Netherlands bro
give this man a fucking promotion give him the give him the
NFL paycheck bro this guy took us the top 16 and took you
for coming to a riot near you Bro, that guy, whoever that
coach is, actually fixed us.
Give him an NFL paycheck right now.
Oh, stop the timer.
Sorry, we won.
Stop the timer.
All right.
Don't worry.
Okay.
Let's see.
It might never happen again.
Don't say that.
What the fuck?
They're like, the way they say it implies we will never do
this again.
There we go.
Look at that.
Oh my god.
Yeah, no.
Shout out to the goalkeeper.
Can we do a watch along at the concert?
Mr. Broken Bonding.
the super chat they could thank you is it during the con oh
my god is it really during the concert before the concert i
don't know yeah no our goalkeepers is really good we did it
guys we're still alive for somehow we're still alive bro
that self-african defender was so clutch like he used up his
two lifelines you know like you know and gays are like you
know two lifelines he used it up didn't have a third baby
you used it all up
oh it's not during the it's not it's not during the concert
guys it's before it's before the concert yeah thank god
thank god the ref's self-african girlfriend cheated on him
and he got the text during halftime and was like oh all
right guess what
Thank God He started playing like fairly now Bro that one
time The ref fucking blocked the ball I was just like what a
fuck Get out of there Like what are you like South Africa's
like I don't know I don't know Are you like the new player
in South Africa What the fuck are you doing
Like the 12th man Yeah he's the 12th man on the field Yeah
Get this guy out of here.
I was like, where does he live?
Right at his city.
Why does Polymarket account?
Oh, Canada.
Our home and native land.
True patron.
I'm sorry, I forgot the lyrics over there.
I always forget it right there.
And that's not where I stop.
True patriot, what?
True patriot love in all of us command.
With glowing hearts, we see the rise.
The true north strong and free from far and wide.
Oh Canada, we stand on God for thee.
God, keep our land glorious and free.
give me the passes give me the pass stats i don't want i
don't care about possessions give me the fucking passes i
need to know where are the pass stats oh you're not gonna
give me the pass stats fucking cowards show me how much of a
pussy south africa was passing
Yeah!
Is that right?
Two yellows, fine.
It was my fault for asking for the yellow card.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Terminator, thank you, the super chat.
Congrats to Canada for winning that match, by the way, Doki.
That last minute winner has just really you from having to
experience extra time and Possibly, yeah, no, fuck that.
I was not ready for that.
Germany, thank you for the super chat thing.
Thank you.
That's us.
Less passes than Algeria.
381 passes.
What about...
538.
Wow.
Who would have thought?
538 fucking passes
daniels thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
thank you my home and native land thank you for the raid
thank you thank you i really appreciate it guys holy is that
toronto oh that's vancouver where is that in vancouver holy
that's a lot of where the fuck is this we're gonna oh
Montreal oh
there's everything no Ryan let's go they're so lucky they're
like we don't get a Ryan let's fucking go well it doesn't
matter I'm a fucking cat that's gonna lose it doesn't matter
guys I'm not gonna cope I'm not gonna cope guys like did you
see how what we did with South Africa, bro.
You see how we play it against South Africa?
If we play like this against Netherlands or Morocco, it's
like they gotta stop the game for pity.
like I gotta like I put leave.
You're right.
Yeah.
But imagine the underdog story.
we made it but we made it though and that's something guys
we made it to top 16 no one believed in us Canadians didn't
believe in us I didn't believe in us in winning the first
game like in the group stages like you guys need to remember
like nobody like really sort of believed during the group
stages and in the moment Bosnia game we're like let's
fucking go we're locked down Canada's always been our like
soccer has always been our favorite sport guys like we've
always been all in on soccer everybody like yeah guys we
live and breathe soccer we've always loved soccer guys we
literally just hockey but what if it's on the grass it's the
country of soccer baby
Many.
Thank you for the super chat.
I thank you.
Thank you.
Playing against Netherlands.
Surrender.
Vote initiated by Kat.
We'll still play.
We just know what we're.
We're not going to be like.
We're totally going to fucking beat Netherlands or Morocco.
We're praying to contact and contact sport.
I swear to God.
I feel like we definitely.
I feel like.
I want to know yellow card stats.
I want to know if Canada's up there.
When it comes to.
yellow cards because I swear to God I definitely see Canada
but Canada definitely got more got more physical than South
Africa during that game like legitimately just fucking
grabbing people's shirt and pushing them every time they're
definitely very aggressive we're bringing hockey to soccer
yellow card is a resource
that was fun that was fun guys i had i had a good time doing
a watch along for this it has been pretty exciting my first
time doing a i guess a soccer watch along um and i had a
great time yeah it's fun i mean like that's what i say like
i don't mind doing watch alongs of like games from my
country because i get more you know it's like the
nationalistic side of me, the more patriotism, you know, my
patriotic side takes over me.
He was like, that's why people love the Olympics and stuff.
But like I said, it's really hard to do watch-alongs for
Canada when, like, of sports I like when they're not, they
haven't been very good at sports that I like for a while.
I feel like as a, when growing up, I've watched more games
from from china than like canada because like like china
goes fucking hard when it comes to the olympics there's more
like chances for china to win like win a lot of medals
during the summer olympics back in the day um um so it's
like so it's but then now now finally canada's good at
soccer yeah fucking finally they're finally good at soccer
can finally like you know care Like, I can finally care,
guys.
Like, I haven't cared about soccer in so long.
They finally are good at an international sport.
We've lost hockey and curling, but we're trying to get
soccer now because the ice caps are melting.
Like, well, it's good for us, guys.
It's good.
We've never been good at soccer.
We're finally there at a level We're not eliminated from the
group stage.
We not only have...
This is the second game we've ever won in the history.
Guys, guys, this is the second game we've ever won in the
history of the World Cup.
Do you know how long the World Cup has been here for guys?
The World Cup has been around for a very long time.
And this is the second game we've ever won in the history of
the World Cup.
This is the best we've ever done.
Yes, it's the 1930s.
Like, guys, we already beat our record.
Two wins.
You know what our record was before this World Cup?
Zero.
We're two, guys.
We're two.
We broke our record of zero.
So I take what I can do.
get it.
It was more than zero.
The two are...
Some people have died, lived, and died.
Never seen Canada win a game.
They would support Canada in World Cup, and people have
lived and died.
Never seen Canada win one game.
But we're all here right now.
We were here.
We saw Canada not only win one game, but we've one two we're
living the canadian dream right now
we're lucky living the canadian we were here this historical
2026 world cup we were here we're oh my god we're we're
making history
it's a part of our heritage oh my god many they even super
chat they never don't say that we can always go up guys
don't make this the last time we get here like decided from
the bottom and now we're here many think it was oh i always
read that sorry i'm so passionate right now i can't believe
If we get top eight we're gonna fucking have a new holiday
The first time It's like soccer day Daddy, these guys
They're national heroes First national team to ever win In
round of 16 Let that sink in folks Daddy, thank you for the
super chat Thank you, thank you In round this is crazy Thank
you, the super chat Thank you, thank you Lucky you, my team
is known as the squad That's got scored off the most in one
game in World Cup history.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We could be the same cat.
That's only three appearances in all of... Yes, and isn't
that sad?
Guys, we've only made it to the World Cup through qualifiers
three times.
We've been invited to the World Cup for so long and we've
only made it three times.
We have not qualified for like barely qualified.
You know, before, like, you know how I thought about when we
got, like, when we got, like, part of the World Cup, like,
when we got invited to host the World Cup, like, I thought
we were just a plus one, like the little brother, you know.
We're like, yeah, well, we have to invite Canada to host it.
Like, they're sort of part of NA.
just America and Mexico and the guy's like Yippee!
We're included!
I was just like, oh my god!
I was like, we get to host with you guys as well?
Like, it'd be weird to exclude Canada from hosting since
they're the America region.
Like, the little brother, that's how I thought.
Like, Yeah, and now, it doesn't matter, we're top 16, we
earned our place, guys.
We fucking earned our place to be part of this tournament.
Yeah, they finally plugged my controller in.
Not anymore.
I'm the little brother with a plugged-in controller.
Guys, we did it.
We can always get better.
we can always get better top 16 Canada God bless Canada oh
I'm happy we needed that win guys I was like bro there's I
literally like I've been awake since like six in the morning
just catching up on all the drama going on earlier I was
like it's still going on I was just like bro I was like why
is still mad.
I thought we moved out.
How is it still going on?
And then I was like, fuck it, bro.
Woo.
World Cup soccer.
It's so dumb.
Yeah.
I was like, oh, like, someone, please create another drama.
Come on.
Move.
Like, we always move.
Yeah, I quit.
People are going to forget this in a week.
Someone just create another drama.
Like, it got so bad.
SureForey responded to the drama on Twitter, guys.
That's crazy.
He's never on Twitter.
He was literally like, bro, what the fuck is this, bro?
And he, like, came in with a steel chair and be like, bro,
this fucking stupid, bro.
Like, yeah.
Yeah.
And someone quick.
We need a new drama to cycle through.
I'm fucking, I don't care about this shit no more.
Like, yeah.
Yeah, but, oh, anyway, that was, uh, that was fun.
I had a, uh, I had a great time, um, watching, uh, today,
uh, boop, boop, boop, uh, let's see.
Yeah, I saw like, sorry, I got.
like a lot of message.
I saw I was so locked in.
I was so fucking locked in to to World Cup.
I tapped to Discord and I just like all these messages.
And not even about World Cup.
They're about fucking other stuff.
it wasn't even about World Cup.
It's got fucking work messages and other messages.
And shit.
Oh, anyways.
celebration music on real quick guys let's see where is it
oh there you go let's go bottom bottom bottom bottom yeah i
had a fun time of course i had a fun time so we're getting
to watch it with you guys too also self-hack no hard
feelings guys just it's just soccer no hard Just, it's just
soccer.
We're just passionate, guys.
I just need to insult them a few more times and they'll
score a goal.
It's got, it's football, guys.
No hard feelings.
Yeah, because the adrenaline's gone.
Now I can say it.
No hard, we follow everyone.
and adrenaline's gone now now i can fucking chillax i will
say our headbutts were so ass i was like bro just stop like
i was just sad seeing this now like
i was just like bro that's just sad i just don't want to see
more headbutts from you guys you just guys guys it's just
head game bro i just can't be bothered watching this anymore
like you know how they you know what how they scored that
goal with their fucking feet like like bro you's wow what a
surprise the goal you finally scored you scored with your
fucking feet not with your fucking head who would have
called it's not called head ball it's football wow are we
all surprised when you score with your feet you win like put
in football yeah ggs no head oh but yeah that's a fun stream
no stream tomorrow i need to rest my voice guys i i think i
yelled a lot today but like i said i have fun time watch
doing the uh world cup watch a lot with all of you guys um i
it was fun reacting to everything with you guys and also
like you know learning more about giving you guys fun facts
about soccer and the world cup and fun facts like you guys
teaching me some fun things too so hey look no offside guess
we didn't have an offside goal though
that's what I was worried about I was just like oh my god I
hope we don't offside because I feel like it's been it's
it's been happening a lot lately I did I am debating if I
want to travel to watch the final game um at the BC place um
because they have one last was it that one last round of 16
game at bc place and i've been wondering because it's
apparently it could be what was it it's like columbia versus
uh it's okay if columbia wins um also i found out there's a
lot of columbians in bc i don't know i was very surprised um
because whenever there were columbian games there were so
many like columbian jerseys like in my complex too so like i
would see so many when i like go walk dad i'll see so many
like uh columbians like coming down the elevator
no it's just like at my that live in my building i was so i
was not i was so surprised i didn't realize like um i didn't
realize there were so many columbians here
there's true british columbia does have columbia in its name
that's true what I'm just thinking, what if that's the
reason they moved to BC?
You know, wait, what if that's the reason?
They're like, British Columbia and Columbia.
Yeah, they got lost and ended up in BC.
Could be, it all makes sense.
Who could Columbia play against?
Or around 60, because it's like, it's on the 7th.
It's on the 7th.
It's like the final match.
It's the final match at BC Place.
But I don't know, like, at the stadium.
But I don't...
It's like question mark, question mark.
But apparently I researched and it said, like, Colombia has
a potential to be there on July 7th.
So I don't...
Ghana?
Is Ghana really good?
Yeah, my voice is gone.
I should stop soon.
Oh, is it Ghana versus Switzerland and, uh, they're decent?
Oh my gosh.
I don't want to get, like, see, like, Ghana.
I feel like Colombia is going to win, right?
Because I feel like Colombia is one of the top teams.
Oh, Switzerland versus Algeria is the other game.
Oh, the round of 16 is Switzerland.
Yeah, but, like, if Colombia wins their game, if Colombia
wins their...
Colombia's fighting Ghana, right?
right so Columbia wins their game against Ghana they travel
to Vancouver yeah so they win they come to uh they go to
Vancouver so I'm wondering who is oh so it'll be Columbia
versus Switzerland okay so it'll be Columbia versus
Switzerland again yeah oh my god do i want to watch
switzerland again though that's the thing i'm like thinking
do i want to fucking watch switzerland again
um oh yeah go to see just to see just to see switzerland
lose that's true i could I could just watch it just to see
Switzerland lose and
yeah they're both red and yeah that's true both red and
white just to hate watch yeah I mean to hate watch you
oh I or I could hate watch them on stream of dollars.
You don't know how spiteful I am.
I paid thousands of dollars to watch Switzerland beat
Canada.
I can pay thousands of dollars to watch Colombia beat
Switzerland.
It's a cycle.
It's...
Just a hate watch.
Or I could hate watch it on stream.
That's true.
That's true, though.
Cool spot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I paid good to watch it lose live.
A true fan.
Hate watching the team that almost knocked you out.
Why do I hate it?
It's because they beat Canada.
No hard feelings, Switzerland.
It's just football.
Please, Doki, we need your luck to beat Ecuador.
Please watch the Mexico game.
Is it today?
Is the Mexico game to get today, guys?
when is it
it's Tuesday I don't think about it guys I don't think about
I didn't get called an honoring Mexican so maybe I'll do it
for you guys what time is it guys what time is the oh Japan
versus Mexico oh that's hard that's hard oh my like yeah
because like which other i know there's only two other like
it's japan and which other asian country uh got um um
qualified because there's only two right oh is it japan
versus brazil oh sorry i thought oh yeah japan versus brazil
is tomorrow okay versus Ecuador.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
I was gonna say, okay, that's fine.
Yeah, I was gonna say that's really hard because Japan's
like the, like, I remember it was like Japan and another
country are like the remaining countries representing Asia.
And so, because like everyone else got knocked out.
So it's like, oh, that's hard.
Choose.
Yeah, Japan versus Brazil would be a Oh, it's just Japan.
Japan's the last podium It's just Japan for Asia.
Yeah, they're like the last The last one the last country
that represent Asia right now So I'm just like I don't know
guys It's just like I don't know if I guys But but if it's
like Japan versus Brazil then I'm fine Brazil God bro I
don't know wait but like guys oh but it's Brazil though it's
Brazil I should live tweet let's Canada finally scored a
fucking good let's go
All right.
I didn't even latch.
We are so passionate.
Oh, sorry.
The adrenaline's, like, coming down right now.
The adrenaline's coming down.
Yeah.
Oh, anyway, I'm going to call it here, everyone.
I'm going to call it here, guys.
Thank you all for coming to watch along with me.
I had such a fun time watching.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture, get up and
around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Guys, you deserve it.
I'll check my schedule to see, like, what I can watch, what
I can and can't watch, guys, for you guys.
So, I don't know much.
The thing is, for me, I don't know much about the other
teams.
I know more about, like, I know the famous teams, obviously,
you know, like, Norway, like, you know, Holland.
I know the famous players, obviously, because, like, you
know, they're iconic.
like everyone knows them like Mbappe, Holland, Messi,
Ronaldo, like stuff like that but I don't know a lot of like
like in the like I don't have like much knowledge on like um
individual teams other than Canada because like you know
they're like honestly like the furthest we've ever been yeah
yeah you know they're the furthest we've ever got here so
like I know a lot of the Canada's team
like so i don't have a lot of knowledge on the other teams
so i you will have to like school me on some stuff if i do
when i do watch uh if if i do watch the other teams most
likely i will i just have to pick and choose which ones i
want to watch yeah um but anyway guys as always everybody
stay hydrated posture check get up and move around to get
that blood flow and you stay up for me head to bed because
you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye
guys Bye.